we've spoken to top ad execs who want to
advertise to developing markets they're
very excited about the potential to
advertise to people through internet.org
yeah how does that benefit users well
I'm not sure it's a big part of the
solution in the near term to be honest I
mean I think what we need to do is work
out a model with operators and
governments and local partners that is
profitable for them so that way they can
continue growing the internet so what
we've found in some of these early
countries that we've worked in Indonesia
the Philippines Zambia now Kenya is you
know you offer a little bit of the
internet for free and more people start
using data and more people access the
internet and can use these tools but
also more people start paying for data
once they understand what they would use
the internet for then people understand
why they would want to pay for data and
these operators end up making more money
and it ends up being more profitable and
then they can take that money and
reinvest it to build a better Internet
infrastructure for everyone in their
country so that ends up being very
important and a lot of what we've
focused on for the last couple of years
is just how do you build a model that's
sustainable for everyone and delivers
free internet to people and originally
we'd thought you know maybe working with
other kinds of partners would be
important but at this point we think we
have a sustainable model that's working
in multiple countries now and there's a
lot of momentum and a lot of countries
are coming online and operators are
coming to us to roll out the
internet.org model and a lot of more
countries so I expect to see a lot more
of the next year so does that mean no
advertising um I don't think it's
necessary to subsidize and make this a
cheap model for Facebook specifically
well I mean again in a lot of these
countries there isn't a very big ad
market yet so it's not that we won't do
it eventually but right now for our
business the main thing that we need to
do is continue making what we're focused
a lot on the quality of the ads and
business experience and doing that in
the developed world in the US and Europe
and Asia and a lot of places there is
actually going to be the biggest driver
of our own profitability and revenue not
trying to make ad markets out of
countries that are just coming online